this word is crystallization or perhaps
also recrystallization because chemists
always want to get the chemicals they
make as pure as possible and a good way
of purifying chemicals is to make
crystals of them when they're in
solution you can have all sorts of
impurities but when they form crystals
the crystals contain much purer compound
than in the solution and the impurities
are left in the solution generally the
crystal is a very precise arrangement of
molecules all the same fitting together
like pieces in some sort of construction
toy the impurity has a different shape
so it doesn't fit in properly
occasionally you're unlucky and you get
an impurity that's the wrong shape and
then you can't get rid of it and each
time you recrystallize the thing so you
make some solution form some crystals
filter them out re dissolve them four
more crystals and so on and each time
you crystallize it you get a pure and
pure compound sometimes in the old days
people crystallized thousands of times
to get something really pure now the
problem is that when you have a solution
even if you want cool it down which is
the standard way of getting crystals to
form the crystals cannot form unless you
give something small some tiny bit for
them to first crystal to form round and
once the first one goes the whole lot
goes sometimes it can just be dirt there
is a famous organic chemist here called
Perkins who invented the dye called move
but he was famous because he had this
huge beard and it was said he was really
successful as a chemist because all
sorts of bits fell from his beard into
the solution and helped the
crystals grow in the solute there are
other examples where people sometimes
scratch the side of their beaker this
forms tiny fragments of glass so that
they also can act as a nucleus for the
crystals formed around one of my friends
David Jones found a student scratching
the wall of the lab with a glass rod and
when he was asked why he said because in
the instructions it says scratch the
wall with a glass rod to get
crystallization but most chemistry
students are much brighter than that so
this is a crystallization
of a really concentrated solution which
is used for warming your hands on cold
days so in here we have a solution I
believe of sodium acetate and it's been
sitting in my desk drawer for years
because although it's a very
concentrated solution there's nothing to
start it crystallizing and inside here
there is a small metal disc you can see
floating around and I believe it may not
work that it reflects this disc it will
be enough to start but in crystallizing
so let's see what happens
reflects the disc that is going
can you see the crystals spreading out
it's getting very warm
what is it getting there is getting boom
because when crystals form when you
bring the ions together they generate
heat so if you feel it put your hand
down here it's nice and warm oh yeah so
it's got an almost solid then you can
see lines of crystals that have grown
along here is now crystallized so what
you do if you're rich you just throw it
away if not you boil it for some hours
in water the solution gets very hot and
everything Reda's all's and then if you
allow it to cool slowly and you've
dissolved up all the crystals it will go
into a solution like it was before and
can sit in my desk drawer for several
more years